you have to have more discipline become
disciplined self-discipline
what's that belief nation it's heaven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
entrepreneurs follow build discipline
also if you want to know at Chaco
willing Jordan Peterson Will Smith and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below people want to
know how to stop the laziness and they
will know how to stop the
procrastination if you're gonna speak
effectively you have to know way more
than you're talking about
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist
[Music]
if you want more freedom in your life
you have to have more discipline if you
don't have any discipline you'll end up
with absolutely no freedom you'll end up
being a slave to other people that boss
you around there's all kinds of problems
that can occur if you don't have
discipline in your life and the more
discipline you have the more freedom
you're gonna have so just that the
discipline of the sales will never it's
impossible to leave no it's possible to
leave there's there's retired seals all
over the place that are undisciplined
they've moved on and they don't care
about that anymore it's fine I don't
judge other people on what they're doing
like they're probably stoked to sleep in
and hang out with their kids and eat
breakfast in bed that's fine
I don't have anything against that look
for me I I want to get up and go we kind
of have this idea that while you're free
as a child and then you let me see if I
can if I can put this properly that you
have a certain delightful wonderful
positive freedom as a child and then
that's given up as you approach
adulthood but the truth of the matter is
is that you have a lot of potential as a
child but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as freedom before you
become disciplined and discipline is a
matter of the imposition of order and
the order is necessary especially for
people who are hopeless and nihilistic
and lots of people are hopeless and
nihilistic way more people than you
think and part of that is because no
one's ever really encouraged them and so
the book is in part a matter of
encouragement it's like lay yourself lay
a disciplinary structure on yourself get
the chaos in in in check and then you
can move towards a state that's freer
because it's discipline first like look
if you're going to become a concert
pianist there's going to be several
thousand hours of extraordinarily
disciplined practice that's the
imposition of order on your potential
let's say but what comes out of that is
a much grander freedom and so in
virtually every freedom that you have in
life that's true freedom is purchased at
the price of discipline so I do scream
to me the other night hey will I want to
be active man I'm gonna be active just
like you you know usually people say
stuff to me like that I'm like yeah man
you do is give them an encouraging word
but I was just sitting here thinking and
it dawned on me 99% of people that say
stuff like that are not willing to do
what it takes to make their dreams come
true the Marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die and that's just real at the
center of bringing any dream into
fruition is self-discipline you know
something something as simple as food
and eating it's not about your body as
much as it is about your mind it's
getting command of your mind to be able
to choose actions that are in your own
best interest every day we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
in the world wants to fight you in the
world's trying to hold you down so you
gonna kick yourself in the balls so you
will stop yourself from getting what you
dream self-discipline is the center of
all material success you cannot win the
war against the world if you can't win
the war against your own mind yo you got
to discipline yourself I started looking
at Mother Teresa
of Gandhi and I was like yo bro Gandhi
would go fast from sex and he was
married he would fast from talking you
know I just started watching these great
peoples like all these people fast and
not about fast and like that's not the
peace but they were very disciplined
people and they would not allow their
exterior world to dominate or destroy
their internal world I just like you I
want to get to a place where I can
control me my family members have grown
a loss too uncle cirrhosis of the liver
brilliant man but just drinking drinking
drinking and I was like yo I do not want
to my father was a substance abuser for
years I was like yo I don't want a life
where something else is controlling me
you know like when I left home and said
I don't want to be controlled no more
like I meant that like I don't know
nothing to control me but me and so I
got to put myself under extreme
discipline to make sure I'm free
so when people
you get up at 3:00 you don't drink you
don't smoke I'm not doing that because I
think I'm better than a BIOS oh I think
you're gonna go to hell because you had
a drink I just want I want to control I
want freedom and for me disciplining
myself means more freedom and unless I
you discipline yourself people who I
told my son other dads like your son
I do not want you to have fun I just
seen a history of people who just have
fun Christmas Thanksgiving Halloween
know there are the people learns that
night every night there are the people
who end up in a 20s having a great deal
of fun but in a 40s and 50s they were
working for somebody and I'm not saying
nothing wrong with cleaning toilets but
they doing something they don't want to
do for the rest of their life and they
can't retire because they played so much
you know so for me I just look at Venus
in Sarina Michael Jackson when he used
to like five and sixes dancing all night
I just think the more man discipline
himself the greater you don't mean it's
gonna happen
but the greater the probability that he
has this sense of freedom the mind is
getting in your own way if you want to
lose weight you know how to do it you
got to eat less you got to work out more
you will lose weight why are you not
doing it self discipline your mind is
getting in your way what I see self
discipline is a positive
I think self discipline has a really
negative connotation a lot of times I
think in a lot of the messages that
people are putting out it comes across
as this really negative thing like you
have to force yourself to do all the
stuff that you really hate and it's
gonna suck but you have to keep going
you got to do it you got to be
disciplined if you're not disciplined
you suck everything's terrible it just
comes across as this really negative
forcing yourself to do stuff that
doesn't resonate with me I see self
discipline as a really positive thing I
think it's really helpful I think it's
amazing and beautiful and golden let's
look at weight as an example I am the
lowest weight that I've been all year
I'm on a routine it's working the
specific strategies that don't really
matter one ain't made it fasting so I'll
only have water and a coffee until noon
and then after that I'll start eating I
do that seven days a week I
for 30 minutes usually at night while
I'm watching the show with my wife seven
days a week and then six days a week
I'll restrict my calories not really
forcing myself not to eat food just not
eating Doritos are not eating junk right
eating healthy food six days a week and
then Saturdays I get to do what I want
six days a week those are the strategies
that I use it may seem like torture but
it's not and the thing that helps me get
through it is the mindset because the
positive of all of this is I'm losing
weight I'm feeling great I'm making
progress I'm super pumped that I'm
getting closer to my goal I feel amazing
about myself so I think self-discipline
usually it seems to focus just on the
action that you just have to grind your
way through it without and not focus on
the mission of what you're trying to
accomplish and how beautiful and
wonderful that is and so yes some of it
might suck right but you're moving
towards something amazing and beautiful
so I think people just focus too much on
the negative part of it and and if you
force yourself to do something that you
hate you can only do it for so long
before you give up if you can't tie it
into the bigger picture of what you're
trying to accomplish then you will give
up and you will quit and you will feel
terrible and then I think having other
people yell at you but how you need to
have self-discipline doesn't actually
help I think it actually makes it worse
because you develop the identity for
yourself of I don't have any self
discipline you can build it it's not
that difficult to do in my perspective
in my view all you need to do is make
sure that you have a really strong why
make sure that you have an outcome that
you are really looking forward to and
you love doing and then the process
itself how do you make the process as
enjoyable as possible
how do you make the process just not
absolutely suck every single day going
in right if you figure that out then you
win I do think that with an it's not
just in sport but with with other things
I do believe that the more you repeat
certain things whether it is writing
working on your you know whether it's
cursive letters or whatever it is like
when you work on something and you keep
doing it over and over it's inevitable
that it will get better and by that
you're creating this feeling of
repetition which leads to discipline
like you know you can do it over and
over again and
that's one of my first one of my first
coaches Robert Lansdorp who I speak
about in the book like that was his
philosophy is you I would take a lesson
from him and his philosophy was just
hitting and grinding and it wasn't about
patterns or anything which you know as I
could get from somebody else but what he
gave me is that feeling that I could hit
the ball from any part of the court and
feel like I could do it with closed eyes
and make it and know exactly where it's
going and I'm for me it started at a
young age like my mom would would make
me memorize this Russian literature that
I did not appreciate at five years old
it was very difficult and I didn't know
what it meant
but I would do it and I would memorize
it and then I would feel that I
accomplished something I don't know why
I don't know but the repetition led me
to this discipline and and I think that
helps with mindset I started Google
AdWords in 2001 okay I was I got lucky I
just stumbled and I was one of the first
people to ever use online advertising I
was in I think the second month Google's
AdWords launched and there was no
YouTube videos there was no Perry
Marshall books there was there was
nothing you just kind of wasted money to
learn now we're the most spoiled
generation everything this computer on
this phone iPhone 7 is more powerful
than the first rocket that put man on
the moon that cost billions of dollars
now we get that for under a thousand
bucks and people are still like I'm lost
yes your loss sit down and then open up
Safari and go how to do Google ads and
you're gonna come up let's see what I
come up with AdWords they have their own
tutorial word stream jump a PHY you got
some paid stuff then you have some free
stuff on HubSpot if you sit in a chair
Charlie Munger calls it assiduity put
your ass in a chair sit there and focus
without being you know the average
American right now the average first in
the world our attention span has dropped
to five seconds the sad news is the
average goldfish has 6 seconds we're now
competing with goldfish and the goldfish
are winning so if you don't have
assiduity
to sit down breed there is no solution
for you you will always be poor because
you'll always be beat by somebody who's
willing to sit in the chair is there a
way for people to build that discipline
yes pain and that's why I'm not a big
believer in delusion you know you asked
me one of the rewiring things we have to
do in this world I'll tell you one you
ever heard this myth everything happens
for a reason so just accept it well
there's kind of truth to that if I jump
off a building and break my legs
yes everything happened for a reason the
reason was gravity like that's why you
break your legs and physics legs brittle
concrete not brittle so that but people
interpret everything happens for a
reason be like well I was meant to learn
from that thing and then BS read Richard
Dawkins The Selfish Gene one of the most
important books written in the last
century he says organisms that only
learn through trial and error lose to
organisms that can learn through other
people's a trial and error is anybody
here we got a little live audience
anybody here ever had to be hit by a car
to learn to look both ways I did it I
kind of learned from just somebody
telling me big car two tons velocity
smash dead and I now always look both
ways so if you're myth is that the only
way you're gonna learn is just through
massive mistakes in trials and error you
have a read Richard Dawkins book how
does pain allow somebody to get more
disciplined okay so going back to that
myth of when you see your life and
anytime there should be pain you go no
no no no it was just how it was meant to
be
no look yourself in the mirror sometimes
and go do you know why I'm not happy
it's because I didn't listen ten years
ago and I got in the wrong career you
know I'm not happy because I married the
wrong damn person it wasn't meant to
happen yes everything happens for a
reason you made a bad choice but it
didn't have to be that way and the
second you build up pain and this by the
way is not my opinion if you talk to
guys like dr. David buss
top ten most cited psychologist in
history okay he's one of my main mentors
he told me I said do adults change like
we do all this self-help videos and
podcasts I said am I wasting my time he
goes yeah kind of
I said why he said well after 25 it's
very hard to teach old dogs new tricks
by the way that's why I've changed
most of my stuff targets people 18 to 25
that's why I do snapchat and all that
because there's hope for 18 to 25 volts
now if you're over 25 before you get the
press he told me but I have good news
for you time I said what he said adults
learn through massive trauma so you will
learn you have to let in some trauma
into your life and that's rough but no
pain no gain like if you are 100 pounds
overweight and you want to be able to
play basketball here's my news for you
everything happened for a reason you got
fat cause you ate too much and you
didn't exercise so welcome to the gym in
the first year is gonna be hell but that
pain hopefully will reprogram your brain
at every time you want to eat that nasty
thing go wait I don't want to go through
that pain again so I think one of the
myths of societies we won't let pain in
we just excuse it all the way like nah
that wasn't inhabit oh you wasted 20
years of life married the wrong person
in the wrong career no tom
it wasn't happy where's the people who
go you you've wasted 20 years and you
will never get it back you better go in
your room and cry and the truth is you
only learn as an adult unfortunately
most people can only change with massive
trauma I love talking about discipline
because I think so many people that word
has such a negative connotation around
it right it just sounds bad discipline
like you're gonna feel pain or someone's
gonna hurt you or or you're in trouble
for something and I want to start having
you think about it in a really positive
way because discipline equals freedom
100% it has been the theme throughout my
entire life is how if you have
structured discipline and you
life and you start doing the things that
you don't want to do especially if you
do them first you are absolutely going
to free yourself of all of the different
pain that comes with not getting your
goals accomplished with comes with that
comes with not taking care of yourself
that comes with living with regret so
before way back in my early 20s and even
through my mid-20s when I would you know
I was trying to create habits around
maybe eating right or habits around
working out and let me tell you habits
around getting stuff done I literally in
my head told myself all the time my
mantra at the time was I never finished
anything so what do you think I did I
finished
nothing because that's literally how I
talked to myself well well I never
finished anything this is another thing
I didn't finish so I had to switch that
mantra around and it was also realizing
how important discipline was and how
much freedom came with it and I spent a
lot of time living in agony in my head
and I was tired all the time because I
spent more of my time in my brain
thinking about what I didn't do and
arguing with myself all day long Joe am
I gonna go to the gym I don't want to go
to the gym you should go to the gym why
aren't you going to the gym you know you
need to go to the gym you're never gonna
get to your goals it's like I was
drained just because of the
conversations I was having with myself
if I would have just gotten disciplined
committed to a time or knew I was going
I could have focused on all of the other
good things that were happening in my
life and just knew this is what I'm
doing it's like just saying okay well
here's what I'm doing so I can forget
about it until the moment that it comes
I'm gonna do it because I'm committing
truly committing to discipline and how
freeing that is and when I started
getting a great discipline habit around
all of the things that I wanted to do I
started to notice how much more free I
felt how much less anxiety I felt how
when my head hit the pillow I felt proud
instead of another day just went by that
I'm further away from my goals and I
have regret and I'm feeling my life
raced by me right the
are all feelings that do not feel good
that discipline can free you from my
guaranteed formula for success that is
100% proven for my life and other people
have taught out work out improve out
less and out strategies again out work
out improve outlets out strategize what
you're looking on the screen here on the
screen look at those four again what
you're looking on on the screen here
which of those four things that you're
looking at the out work out improve
outlets out strategize which of those
four things do you think comes last
meaning you'll learn the latter the
latest it's out strategize why because
that requires a lot of experience it's
like you got to go through like a
general in the war right you've got to
go through so many different words to
learn different strategies and what
works and what tactics works on what
doesn't work that's something you gotta
be working on right however the other
three out work if a guy works 80 hours a
week and you work 40 hours a week you
can't compete with that guy if some if
you yourself are reading two three four
books a month and you develop in your
mind and your competitor is not and he
only reads one or two and you study in
industry articles and all the subs and
they're not you know you're studying how
to recruit CEO CFO CEO CMOS what is the
best way to stretch this million dollar
investment that I got to make this
happen who should I talk to to be part
of a group for mentors and CEOs group
and all these who should I network with
what community should I be a part of
who's the best engineers IT firm to hire
what are these competitors doing what
are some of the guys that are not even
on my mark if you start studying those
industry somebody else isn't it's tough
to compete with you and then outlast
some people work 80 hours a week for a
year and that's great but they can't
work 80 hours a week for three years
some work 80 hours a week for three
years but you work 80 hours a week for
five years you outlasted the guy that
the three years are one year they can't
compete with you because the compounding
effort favors you so these four things
that you look at on the screen require
one thing and that's discipline and the
discipline part you don't hear a lot
about that's the things people doing
nobody else sees that's when you win how
do you control
how do you discipline how do you start
monitoring what you're saying to
yourself I can't find the right girl I
can't find the right guy
a marriage is hard
I'm broke I'm poor it's gonna be hard if
you don't change your mind you got to
change the way you think and a way to
change the way you think first of all
the one way is to start discipline
yourself catch yourself every time you
say I don't have time say hey I create
time every time you say I know have
money I create money literally like
talking to yourself hey I am a
millionaire so if you're broke right now
quit saying I am broke and start saying
what you want where are you going
it's not complicated you want to get
rich I got rich you want to get rich you
can nothing and no one stopping you can
do that but the information
these thoughts that we have we think
there are thoughts or makes it really
hard to change them people meditate try
to not think possible show me some of
your thumb that successfully
consistently the [ __ ] hey everybody
the mind thinks thoughts but here's the
distinction if I told you a hundred
years ago we're gonna fly to the moon
and back you would call me a lunatic
that's where the term comes from people
still use it it doesn't make any sense
because a lunatic if somebody thought we
gotta move back we've done it right but
if I would have told you a hundred years
ago that there's gonna be a box in your
pocket and you're gonna pull this thing
out you're gonna hit a couple buttons
and then it's gonna capture invisible
waves that are drifting around the earth
and bring the waves in and you're gonna
see somebody on the other side of the
earth and you're gonna talk to them
you're totally nuts thoughts are those
invisible waves and when you use your
body in a certain way if I sit like this
I'm gonna channel I'm gonna tap into a
different channel those waves than if
I'm sitting like this kind of like a TV
set if I turn one channel might be a
comedy channel I'm gonna see a lot of
laughter turn another one it's a horror
channel turn another channel it's a
romance channel this is what changes
which of those waves you touch in so if
you can start to realize that your cloth
do you think are your thoughts there's
nothing unique about your thoughts
they've been around for thousands of
years you're just tapping into the
because of what you're doing with your
body that makes you too fearful or
passion or too courageous or whatever
you're feeling as you go in those states
you get different thoughts so what I
want people to see is that learn how to
just see those thoughts go by it's
learning how to be entertained by those
thoughts cuz I have crazy thoughts then
but what I've got good at is going look
at that crazy thought That's not me
that's the mind not your mind cuz if
it's you how do you change you pretty
hard but I really truly know there's I
haven't heard a thought come out of you
that's original you've called them your
thoughts but they're not you've stolen
them they've been around forever
when you see that it's easier to let go
of them and letting go of those thoughts
is one of the ways that you free
yourself and then again the more you do
it just like a muscle you get better and
better better than all of a sudden they
used to make you crazy or stressed out
or make how many things you'd be worried
about that never came to be and some
people their life
good so they worry about other people
they're never not worried right so it's
really just a pattern if you want wealth
real wealth is not just money it's
emotion that's like what are we really
after in money you know on money you
want pieces of paper with the pictures
of deceased notables on it you want we
think money will give you think it'll
give you freedom or security or
stability or love it won't give you a
lot it'll get you sex it won't get you
love right so really what you're after
is the emotion and so what I want people
to get is the emotion they want down all
it is is a new habit it's learning to
discipline this mind right by realizing
the main thoughts are out there and
letting them float by and constantly
coming back to what can I love about
this what can I appreciate it's like if
you can learn to love or at least
appreciate start to enjoy the things
that used to get upset about how much
freedom would you have how much more joy
you have and I know people got billions
of dollars I've coached them who's like
holy [ __ ] they live and scarcity all the
time when man I'll never forget he's
screaming at his wife I'm in the meat I
mean I'm in the house and he's screaming
at his wife because she spent some money
on a bunch of outfits and stuff like
that he's a multi-billionaire he
couldn't spend all his money in his
lifetime and then he's totally upset at
his daughters in her 20s who spent some
money too and I'm like I pulled over saw
afterwards and I said what do you do
this for and what do you do it for it
he's like well it's just it's the
principle thing I said no the principle
thing is do you love these people and do
you want them to have an abundant life
when you have you don't have one loss
but you live like you're poor you know
it's like I finally got through them but
so many people that's what I say money
doesn't change you money magnifies who
you are so you want to expand the depth
of who you are and free yourself from
suffering by just knowing it's a pattern
of thought and you can change the pout
of the phone raise your standard Apple
at the core is core value
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the way people now
one drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance a man if you liked this video
and want more check out the one I made
on what is stopping you from success the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when I was at rock bottom I didn't
know that I was at rock bottom and you
can't really change what you're not
aware of